parmi les smartphones de samsung de
cette année il ya beaucoup de nouveaux
modèles il ya le modèle très haut de
gamme que vous connaissez avec les
galaxy s 10
elles se disent plus s10 ceux qui sont
vraiment très bien il ya une autre vie
ce qui va arriver d'ici quelques temps
et puis une vraie refonte de milieu de
gamme et de l'entrée de gamme la gabegie
et les gamins ont fusionné font sentir
des blacks sont vraiment très sympa et
notamment comme le samsung galaxy à 70
ce que je vous ai déjà présenté il ya
quelques temps et dans cette gamme à il
ya des modèles qui sont un peu plus
d'entrée de gamme notamment le samsung
galaxy à 20 e
celui-là eux pour essentiel donc c'est
un nouveau modèle qui est un petit peu
en parallèle est ce qu'on peut avoir sur
la gabegie avant de chez samsung
j-6 et compagnie et là je dois
reconnaître que je trouve que autant
samsung apps une belle montée en gamme
sur pas mal de ses produits pour les
rendre vraiment actuelle notamment par
rapport à la concurrence chinoise qui
est de plus en plus pressante
autant sur la 20 e pour moi c'est pas ça
on n'y est pas la copie n'est pas bonne
le packaging n'est pas génial alors
après il faut chercher à gratter un peu
de tous les côtés mais le vrai problème
que rencontre sa 20e alors il ya des
défauts dans le smartphone ya des
défauts majeurs que vous les énoncés
mais c'est pas tant les défauts du
smartphone c'est plus la concurrence est
très difficile et avec un smartphone
comme un galaxy avait eu pour moi
clairement là ça me saoule vous n'êtes
pas là autres
[Musique]
le gros challenger du samsung galaxy à
20 e pour moi c'est leur ennemi note 7
qui est largement au dessus de shiomi
parce qu'en termes de tarifs en les
notes de monsieur heureux ce smartphone
le galaxy avant le coup de 189 euros et
leurs ennemis note 7 coûte 10 euros de
plus
199 euros 90 et pourtant entre les deux
smartphones il y a franchement un monde
y est c'est à mon avis là dessus qu'on
va vraiment buts et samsung laisse moi
vous montrer en détail ce qu'il en est
et à vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire même si
donc on vous dit ça il y avait eu est
pas vilain il est pas non plus à la
hauteur de ce qu'on pourra voir sur
d'autres smartphones dans l'entrée de
gamme le dos est en plastique et ce
quand même pas mal de traces de doigts
bon ça vous me direz que c'est pas bien
grave
je ne suis pas hyper fan de cette partie
au niveau de la caméra arrière on
retrouve un capteur d'empreintes
digitales ça c'est assez standard après
bon les finitions sont quand même
relativement pas trop mal vous avez la
recharge en usb type c vous avez une
prise jack qui est situé juste la
première recharge est très facilement
vous avez votre qui aura deux cartes sim
de 4,6 plus une carte microsd pour
l'extension de mémoire et vous avez un
écran qui n'est somme toute pas vilain
on a une petite encoche goutte d'eau
c'est pas vilain par contre on a quand
même un menton qui est assez proéminent
très gros ça s'agace un petit peu la
fête à côté de ça lorsque vous le voyez
comme ça c'est pas mal on est sur les
formes avec des écrans de 5,8 pouces qui
tiennent bien dans la main qu'on peut
utiliser une main ça s'est relativement
bien maintenant là dessus il ya pas mal
de défauts à commencer par son écran on
a beau avoir un écran que 5,8 pouces est
relativement sain par aso 19 points 5/9
qui est bien la résolution est quand
même à mon avis relativement trop faible
à dessus par rapport à la concurrence
1560 par 720 pixels c'est du hd plus
c'est clairement pas suffisant
en plus vous avez un écran après ça
c'est standardiste à l'écran lcd c'est
du tft on n'est pas sur le lit ps on
n'est pas sur ce qui aura le mieux en
terme de lcd même si c'est vrai que je
trouve qu'il fait quand même pas trop
mal le job
maintenant il ya tout qui m'a vraiment
frappé lorsque j'ai commencé à
l'utiliser que j'ai fait le premier
réglages
c est la lumière bleue j'ai l'impression
je peux me tromper qu'on en prend quand
même pas mal dans les yeux lorsque vous
avez quelque chose qui est assez blanche
attire tout de suite un peu sur le bleu
c'est pas génial pour marque samsung
maîtrise vraiment ces dalles en règle
générale la sur ce smartphone avec cette
dalle lcd tft pour moi le rendu est pas
génial en plus on a beau avoir connu à
l'intérieur
qui est vachement bien vous n'avez pas
la possibilité de venir régler la
couleur en tout cas de votre écran donc
il s'y est pas venir atténuer le bleu il
est comme il est il ne bouge pas voilà
c'est pareil là dessus je trouve ça un
peu moyen même pour une effrayante
multimédia south est relativement
correct bon y'a rien de dingue mais une
fois de plus l'expérience est un peu
gâchée et je trouve que cette fois-ci
par l'audio vous avez un petit haut
parleur mono son côté qui clairement n'a
pas beaucoup de puissance en plus de ça
le son est relativement pas terrible
donc ça gâche un peu la fête
vous avez en plus ici là juste là une
petite prise jack pour venir brancher
votre casque ce que vous voulez fut dans
l'absolu pas mal ça permettra d'avoir
une meilleure qualité que ce que
d'écouter à travers les haut parleurs
mais c'est pas non plus complètement
dingue et c'est vrai que de ce point de
vue là je trouve que l'expérience est un
peu gâchée lorsque vous allez regarder
des vidéos
lorsque vous allez jouer à des jeux
cépages et la chanterelle s'élancer à
sfax nitro j'arrive absolument pas le
lancer voyez j'ai la musique mais j'ai
l'écran gameloft qui restent allumés
comme ça ça me fait planter en fait le
smartphone et pour marca sera qui trop
c'est justement injecté très léger pour
les smartphones justement que le patro
puissance la voyez ce cas rien faire il
se passe absolument rien et je suis
vraiment vraiment embêté alors j'essaye
voyez up
qu'est ce qui se passe rien je te passe
à grand chose
la hesse qui revient sur le côté des
fois oui des fois non et ça je comprends
pas a pourtant je suis sûr bien sûr
l'art à saillé à sa part ça bloque alors
qu'est ce qui se passe ça marche ça
marche pas j'essaie d'en venir
je reviens dessus voyez ça rame ça
marche
enfin ça veut bien mais le truc
absolument pas sélectionné ni l'âge ni
rien alors je pense que dans quelques
instants j'ai pouvoir le faire mais ça
c'est pas acceptable sur un smartphone
comme ça on est quand même un smartphone
coûte presque 200 euros c'est pas
possible d'avoir des problèmes comme ça
ah ça y est je te met mon âge ne
s'affiche pas donc là pour moi très
clairement j'arrête ça fonctionne
absolument pas et ça voyez ça montre
vraiment le problème des gens on a un
problème de positionnement sur kde et
hop près ça commence un peu bougé je ne
comprends pas
j'essaye de l'appuyer pour l'éteindre
j'ai encore un peu la musique derrière
l'âge est un bon smartphone on est
d'accord donc là vous imaginez vous êtes
dans les transports en commun vous êtes
n'importe où vous voulez couper le truc
alors est-ce que je peux baisser le son
j'essaye de baisser le son ça n'est ce
pas et c'est problématique
ça commence un peu à réagir nos
clairement là dessus pour moi il ya un
souci on n'a pas le truc le plus haut en
termes de performances en exil aux 7884
vous avez 3 giga de ram 32 gigas de
stockage extensible jusqu'à 512 ya grâce
à une carte micro sd mais ce qui est
quand même pouf
c'est que même ses choix que de produits
et pas forcément hyper bien positionné
par rapport à la concurrence
un smartphone comme celui là je le
verrais plus autour des 130 euros pour
qu'ils puissent être vendus vu ce qu'ont
à la concurrence 130 euros ça pourrait
passer mais là jusqu'à la concurrence
est vu en plus les problèmes que jeune
arrière sur un asphalte ni trop ça pour
moi ça passe pas l'autonomie n'est pas
dit non plus vous à une batterie de 3000
millions période avec une recharge
rapide 15 watts l'autonomie pour moi
c'est pas gg vous allez pouvoir regarder
l'événement peut être une bonne journée
pourquoi pas mais c'est pareil je trouve
que de ce point de vue là c'est pas
complètement dingue y a un truc est
aussi un peu négligé par samsung
je trouve sur ce produit là vu une fois
de plus en positionnement tarifaire
c'est la boîte
le packaging est pas génial je trouve
que bon voilà pressé c'est pas vilain
c'est pas non plus un truc trop moche
mais vu ce qu'ils peuvent proposer
est ce qu'ils savent faire alors
peut-être pour y aller à l'économie je
ne sais pas ce que c'est pas
complètement génial alors bon c'est pas
là vraiment effectivement ça va ça va
gâcher la fête mais je trouve que voilà
ce type de d'ouverture vu ce que sait
faire samsung ça mon avis c'est pareil
chez moyens fans il y aussi une partie
la blesse c est la partie photo vous
avez deux capteurs à l'arrière et un
capteur à l'avant alors vous avez un
capteur principal qui situe juste à la
salle 13 mégapixels une ouverture de f
1.8 qui a un angle de 76 degrés et vous
avez un deuxième capteur qui va être là
pour le mode portrait c'est un ultra
grand-angle de 123 degrés capteur 5
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 et à
l'avant juste là cachés ici vous avez un
capteur de 8 mégapixels une ouverture de
f 2.0 sur le papier comme ça on se dit
pourquoi pas ça peut le faire mais le
rendu est franchement pas génial la
seule chose qui le sauve c'est les
photos en plein jour avec le capteur
principal
je vous montre quelques photos voici une
photo prise avec le capteur principal je
trouve quand même un peu sursaturé après
ça fait la faire là dessus ça me paraît
pas non plus complètement grave ça
marche
et là je vais arriver sur le grand-angle
tout de suite je trouve ça moins précis
on sait pas trop où le point est fait
pour ça un peu floue partout et puis
surtout c'est pas très très beau la
couleur est pas bien vous allez voir sur
une photo capteur principal
ça va ça fait à peu près à faire là on
passe en grand-angle tout de suite c'est
beaucoup moins bien mais c'est pas
vraiment là-dessus qu'on s'en rend
compte
capteur principal ça fonctionne le grand
angle
voyez c'est pas beau il ya un côté un
peu cireux un peu jaunâtre une gestion
de la couleur qui équipent à maîtriser
là dessus c'est pas terrible petit
fleurs sympathique bon ça c'est assez
sympa et là vous arrêtez ce grand temps
que tout de suite vous savez pas où est
ce que le point est fait on n'arrive pas
à le faire c'est impossible en appuyant
pu le faire le point et on arrive sur
une jolie petite fleur avec une jolie
petite abeille à l'intérieur pour
lorsque vous regardez comme ça ça
passait pas complètement dingue mais ça
passe et on arrive sur la photo que le
grand-angle et là franchement on va pas
se mentir
excusez moi c'est dégueulasse la gestion
de la couleur tout s'est vraiment pas
beau là c'est complètement surexposé la
rdc complètement blanc on retrouve
n'aime pas la couleur de la fleur je
trouve en plus qui a coûté déformant
dans l'image je me serais abstenu de
mettre un ultra grand-angle de 5
mégapixels j'aurais juste garder le
deuxième capteur juste pour les faits
évoqués pour mode portrait là je pense
qu'à une grosse erreur stratégique il
aurait vraiment fallu ne pas le faire
quelque chose là dessus a beaucoup comme
sa principale je trouve un peu de termes
niveau de l'image et j'arrive après
volée jacques huppert un local alain
petit plat au resto capteur principal ça
va ça fonctionne genf au grand-angle bon
voilà c'est ni fait ni à faire
juste une petite photo et les caméras de
celle fille s'est pas complètement d'un
mais ça marche parce que des conneries
tu sois mode portrait là rien ne va plus
j'ai pas réussi à fonctionner pourtant
j'ai essayé différents moyens j'ai
essayé différents différentes astuces
qui salissent vachement âge une tête un
organe est pas là dessus regardez comme
c'est lycée j'ai un visage qui lie cette
shellys et le traitement est vraiment
pas terrible gpat louche moi partons
c'est diane mode portrait j'étais bien
dessus j'ai fait ce qu'il fallait et
j'ai vraiment fait plusieurs essais et
pourtant à aucun moment j'ai un flou
d'arrière plan là et j'avoue je ne
comprends pas non plus je dois
reconnaître que je suis vachement
embêter samsung j'adore ce que vous
faites j'aime beaucoup vos produits je
trouve que dans le haut de gamme
s'étoffe d'un milieu de gamme meibo
produits et notamment les galaxies à 70
ce que je recommande pour vraiment bien
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas vu mon test vous
invite à aller le voir
j'adore les galaxies boys qui sont juste
derrière
sheila voilà la petite boîte avec mes
petits galati belges adorent les
galaxies bottes je crois que il ya
vraiment un beau boulot de la parole de
samsung est une belle progression
il ya une belle remise en question ayant
plus manuels qui est vachement bien
cette année et vous savez samsung puis
quand on aime les gens il faut leur dire
que ça va pas et ça ça va pas du tout
pour moi le galaxy à 20 il n'a pas sa
place dans la gamme alors est ce qu'il
ya des problèmes derrière logiciel est
ce qu'il faut améliorer d'un point de
vue logiciel peut être est ce que j'ai
reçu un modèle défectueux
ça me paraîtrait quand même bizarre mme
le smartphone tourner le problème dans
ce parti trop ça me paraît quand même
vraiment bizarre le fait d'avoir fait le
choix de mettre un 5 mégapixels
grand-angle c'est une très mauvaise idée
le rendu n'est pas du tout qualitatif
l'aurait juste le garder 5 mégapixels
pour le mode portrait mais pas plus ce
mode portrait ne fonctionne pas le
smartphone pour moi n'est pas terrible
et malheureusement je ne peux pas vous
le conseiller parce que je ne trouve pas
terrible je préfère à ce moment là si
vous voulez un smartphone de samsung
dans l'entrée de gamme d'aller sur le
gie 6 de l'année dernière que je trouve
bien mieux que le galaxy à 20 e de cette
année voilà je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez dites moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire dites moi comment vous le
trouvez est-ce que vous avez d'autres
produits de samsung j'imagine que oui
peut-être pas peut-être pas vous mais il
y en a beaucoup qui ont des produits de
samsung à des produits vraiment qu'ils
sont cool mais ça noël voilà on passe
notre chemin et ont dès demain vous
embrasse ciao